[Music]
um and so we uh did that experience and
then we got to the evening and then we
were like I was I was trying my best to
figure out a good way to introduce them
to uh Tokyo and Japanese nightlife and
just drinking culture here and stuff
like that and I was thinking you know
maybe in maybe in Izakaya would be like
good and stuff like that for sure and
Sydney was like no oh god let's listen
let's not do that uh Sydney's like let's
go to a girl's bar oh my gosh
because because it's because it's Sydney
why why does she want to go to a girl
Spa because it's Sydney I know Sydney
Sydney probably walked in was like don't
worry they know me let me genuinely like
enjoys going going to girls
and so one of the first ones because she
just wants to talk right yeah she just
wants to talk Japanese one of the first
places we go so it's uh me Sydney her
parents and her uncle and auntie right
she goes up to one of these girls uh who
is promoting promoting like a random
girls bar or something like that and she
goes oh can I can we have a can we have
a
uh do you have space for sex
and uh the girl goes yeah and then
Sydney calls over her family and just
the realization in the girl's face where
she realizes the customer base that
she's bringing in is so far beyond so
far removed from the customer base she
is used to like a group of American
tourists not even young American
tourists just like a family
the girl's probably like you you do
realize what you're about to go into
right like this isn't a diner no we
don't do that here yeah we don't do that
yeah and so um and so we we go in and
it's it's a very small girls bar so
there's not really like any tables there
sure there's one like L-shaped counter
and that's kind of it so I'm like okay
Sydney you take that side and I'll take
the other side just so you know just so
there's always someone who can kind of
speak Japanese on either side yeah the
girls want to like get friendly and uh
talk to talk to the family members and
stuff like that and so I sit next I sit
next to Sydney's mum and Sydney sits on
the complete opposite side of the bar
and so the girls come over and they
start talking and explaining the system
of this bar uh which was uh which my
parents uh sorry which Sydney's parents
and family were just like as what's what
kind of service do they offer here I
don't really understand because uh they
they came over and they were like so
it's uh it's thirty dollars per hour uh
uh and uh you know you can order all of
these drinks from the menu so in the
typical girls bar you kind of you kind
of pay for the company yes right yeah
the drinks are just kind of included to
keep you paid to talk to girls basically
yeah you basically I was trying to find
the way the best frame of reference to
explain what a girl's bar is
to uh Sydney's family because they were
they were like as Fish Out of Water as
you can get yeah they were probably just
expecting a box it's like it's like it's
like Hooters except you don't pay for
the drink you pay for the time you're at
Hooters yes yeah so the way I explained
it was okay stick with me for a second
um so you know how in America they have
strip clubs right I was like
okay this is like a terrible route that
was the first thing that came to mind oh
my God I did not think of who this [__]
I should have said Hooters it's like
strip club without the stripping yeah so
so imagine imagine strip clubs you have
strip clubs yeah and I was like stick
with me for a stick with me for a second
so it's kind of like strip clubs but
instead of paying for girls to strip uh
you pay for girls to converse with you
yeah and so the girls are incentivized
to be very very friendly to the customer
base and Converse with you yeah and um
so I that's what I explained before
going in and uh even explaining that I
don't think my especially my
mother-in-law was prepared for let's say
how uh energetic and in character the
girls were going to be right
POV your Sid's mum you're you're used to
like very local Friendly Midwestern bars
and stuff like that and you come in and
there's a cute captains Japanese Goku
Going like ah
was it like uh it was like a themed one
or is it just like a bog standard like
this it was it was a themed one it was
like a kind of like a uh I think they
were in like Chinese dresses and stuff
like that I'm not sure what the exact
theme was all right yeah yeah but I've
been to like plenty of girls bars uh
because of Sydney I should say probably
like the only probably the only goal
probably only like girlfriend that
actually drags their partner to girls
bars but uh yeah some girls bars can be
like some girls bars you can tell
they're just there for the costume yeah
yeah and some girls bars you they're
there and they're actually like really
enjoying their job and in character and
stuff like that um this was the latter
one so it was like a very very energetic
girls bar
um so the first thing that happens uh
that happens is I sit next to Sydney
takes one side I take the other one of
the girls comes over and she asks
yeah
she asks if she asks if uh she asks if
my mother-in-law is my girlfriend
because that's that's
his mom was flattered by that
I just I just like no no no no no this
is this is this is my mom this is my mom
please this is my mum she's like oh
Carson and I was like I had to like I
didn't know the exact word for
mother-in-law yeah yeah yeah but that's
just um yeah sure they kept calling
Sydney's mom bijin
beautiful which is just like the
Japanese word for like beautiful woman
right and uh they um I they I think they
complimented Sydney's mum more than they
complimented Sydney
did Sydney like that or perhaps it was
certainly uh happy about battle uh
Sydney can hear her but I was I was I
was I told I told I was telling Sydney
like halfway through they're like
they're like really like your mom like
they they're simping over your mouth
they're kind of like all the girls here
are kind of like simping over here
did Cindy's mom enjoy it oh she enjoyed
the hell out yeah I bet honestly
[__] amazing experience like this
Sydney took like a massive 50 50 in like
interesting 1910 yeah
very much a 90-10 kind of experience on
whether it's whether they would have
hated it or whether they would have like
really relucked the experience but one
thing I realized is that if you have the
right girls bar which is a toss-up
because it's hard to find it's hard to
find because girls bars can be
completely different Vibes depending on
what kind of bar you go to yeah
um these girls clearly enjoyed their job
and clearly just wanted to set a good
vibe I felt bad because we walk in and
the only other person in there was this
like old Japanese businessman
that's how they always are and you can
see his face come you can see his face
where a bunch of like American tourists
comes in and uh because he's obviously
like a regular there
um and now all the girls are going
towards and all the girls are now simply
towards Sydney's mom and he's just like
great
but um oh that's awesome but yeah uh
like they were very like iffy about it
going in uh seeing the kind of vibe and
seeing like oh what kind of what kind of
place has Sydney dragged me into uh but
if you find the right girls bar they are
so good at setting like a good vibe and
something like a shortly Vibe yeah
um that's
you know it's it's just it's just a
really fun time honestly uh and Sydney's
mum had a great time I was telling her
all of the compliments that all the
maids were saying to her uh Sydney like
now is so acclimated to girls bar she
walks in like a [__] mafia boss she
sits down she knows how things work she
knows she knows exactly what to say to
get like the good treatment right right
um and we we come out and actually one
of one of Cindy Uncle one of Sydney's
Uncle who's comes up to me and he goes
you know what probably a good thing I
don't I don't live in Japan because I
would spend way two minutes I would
spend way too much money in bars like
that man and I was like oh oh no oh no
no no no no no no no no no no no no oh
yeah did you tell them they could tip
sorry they can counter tip in those bars
you can buy the gold strings yeah oh
yeah yeah yeah so I told them about uh
Sydney did all the siblings oh she was
like whatever you guys want buy a drink
to my mom yeah I I remember I was in one
of those bars with Time and
um I was with a friend there and the
girl was very persistent when I was like
what do you I was like oh yeah get a
drink and then she was like Dom Perignon
and I was like no no what like how much
is that she said two grand I'm like no
sure and then I kept I was like just
pick another Drake she's like how about
this other Dom Perrier what
what yeah and so I was explaining to my
uh mother-in-law uh so be careful yeah
so I explained to Sydney's mom and her
aunt that you know there's like the
opposite of girls bars as well there's
like host clubs bars as well and as soon
as I as soon as I said that after the
girls bar experience they were like tell
me more
uh the mum and the aunt
tell me more about this there's two
types for guys there's there's hosts and
then there's just guy snack bars yes
right it's basically girls bars they
just talk to you and they compliment you
and stuff yeah the hosts are more like
HOSA like the one-on-one like here to
flirt with you make you fall in love
with me and I'm gonna like string you on
as long as you keep buying drinks yeah
yeah it's like they're they like guy
snack bars do exist and they're pretty
common as well yeah right I mean it's
the same in with the girls side as well
there's girls bars and then there's oh
that's right I like host clubs where
it's like the girls are there to like
sit with you and to like make you fall
in love with them so you can buy them
drinks yeah yeah because uh because I
honestly think if you want to like learn
to practice your Japanese
um the girls girls bars are like
honestly a great [__] place yeah
right for sure um honestly you can also
go to a place like golden guy as well
where you have normally have very
talkative songs hey you know 50 bucks an
hour for a private lesson when you pay
30 bucks and free alcohol yeah you can
drink all you want it's free alcohol
well it's not free alcohol it's the it's
thirty dollars for all that's a
dangerous mindset hey hey if it's 30
bucks for an hour it's free yeah it's
free I can get through way more alcohol
than that that's what I mean that's true
yeah and you know it's it's it's nothing
most of the time nothing sleazy about it
you're just paying for company and
they're they're just a mindset if you
want him feeling sleazy it's gonna feel
sleepy yeah I'm just gonna hang out
support a local business yeah learn
Japanese not sleazy yeah establish a
platonic relationship yeah it's a
healthy non-uh parasocial relationship
yeah because you know talking to you
talking to some of the girls there and
uh Sydney has talked to a lot of girls
who has worked at different girls bars
as well and a lot of the girls honestly
work there just because it's like a
release for them because a lot of times
they it's they're like really really
extroverted and it's just the perfect
job for them just to be able to like
socialize yeah just let loose in Japan
which can sometimes be really really
hard in a lot of different like jobs and
different social situations as well so a
lot of the times if you find the right
girls uh girls bars they want to talk to
you as much as you know you are looking
for conversation as well they they
genuinely enjoy their job and you're
like there's some there's something just
nice about seeing someone who just
genuinely enjoys what they do yeah and
they're just happy to do what they do
and so that was like day one uh they
packed in pretty early day one that was
day one how long are they here for
they're here for a week so that's gonna
be the most eventful week for a very
long time it's not a very long time
um but I mean if that was all one day
then this the week is gonna be [__]
yeah the only reason the only reason we
didn't go on for longer because I did
want to introduce them to like karaoke
and you know or and you know other just
other more traditional Japanese bars
maybe kind of went in on the team
there's nothing more traditional than a
girl's party that's true that's the most
traditional yeah honestly how last time
went I wouldn't be surprised if they
asked to go to more girl Spas if I'm
being honest Good Vibes but uh that was
day one we packed it in early because
they were jet lagged and everything like
that so uh but honestly for like the
first day of traveling from America that
was I thought I thought I wouldn't have
anything to say coming in to like this
podcast because I was like I'll talk
about it when the Trip's over and I'm
like [__] it are we there's so much more
stories in a week yeah so much is
happening just one day I'm glad they're
having a good time at least you know I
think honestly Sydney's kind of like a
Banff for just being so fearless and
just being like nope but Mom Dad you're
just gonna come here and uh I'm not
gonna try and ease you into it I'm just
gonna throw you out the deep end because
this is what I want to do
I'll see you I'll see if your parents
I feel they might not have the same
reaction yeah you should be like Mom Dad
have you heard of a girl's mom
let's go
I can't even imagine what that'd be like